y
[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24
expectativa en eeuu por el inicio del
juicio contra tarek saving el ex policía
acusado de asesinato en segundo grado
por la muerte del ciudadano
afroamericano george floyd quien estaba
bajo su custodia
el movimiento black black matters espera
una condena ejemplar que siente
precedente en ese país norteamericano
otras dos personas murieron en una nueva
jornada de manifestaciones ciudadanas en
mianmar que terminaron en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad varios sindicatos hicieron un
llamado a una huelga general para
mostrar su rechazo a la junta militar
que tomó el poder a través de un golpe
de estado el pasado primero de febrero
en france 24 conmemoramos el día
internacional de la mujer con una serie
de reportajes especiales sobre mujeres
excepcionales en tiempos de pandemia en
esta ocasión les presentamos la historia
de denis habrás es una cirujana dentista
que cuida la salud oral de los pacientes
que están entubados y atendidos en salas
de cuidado intensivo
muy buenos días estamos en vivo desde
los estudios de france 24 en bogotá en
colombia soy santiago lópez gracias por
acompañarnos hasta ahora vamos a
comenzar en eeuu este lunes comienza el
juicio contra derek chauvín el ex
policía de la ciudad de minneapolis
acusado de matar al ciudadano
afroamericano george floyd mientras
estaba bajo custodia policial
su fallecimiento desencadenó una ola de
protestas y de disturbios que sacudió a
eeuu durante varios meses también dio
pie al surgimiento del movimiento black
life matters que clamó por cambios en la
policía de ese país álvaro cordero nos
cuenta más
el 25 de mayo de 2020 el policía direct
shopping mató a george floyd un
ciudadano afroestadounidense al
asfixiarlo por más de nueve minutos con
su rodilla las imágenes conmocionaron a
minnesota y pronto comenzaron las
protestas la violencia policial y el
racismo fueron el objeto de la ira de
miles de personas durante días y las
principales ciudades del país comenzaron
a marchar en memoria de floyd algo que
tambaleó la política estadounidense y
llegó a las puertas a la casa blanca
george flores wenger la memoria de georg
floyd está siendo deshonrado por
alborotadores a saqueadores y
anarquistas la violencia y el vandalismo
están siendo liderados por antifaz y
otros grupos radicales de izquierda que
están aterrorizando inocentes y
destruyendo trabajos
jobs donald trump fue muy crítico con
las protestas y sacó a la guardia
nacional en varias ciudades para sofocar
las pero la ola de manifestaciones
alentada por el movimiento black lives
matters traspasó fronteras y llenó las
calles de cientos de ciudades del mundo
como parís roma o londres
estas personas no exigían solamente
justicia para georges floyd sino que
también querían
históricas y estatuas de esclavistas
como eduard coll stone cayeron el 9 de
junio georges floyd recibió un gran
homenaje durante su funeral un acto que
sirvió para reivindicar su figura y
exigir justicia y una reforma profunda
de lo que consideran racismo
institucional
quiero justicia para mi hermano mi
hermano mayor todos lo recordarán en
todo el mundo él va a cambiar el mundo
es el humor de la gente derecho bin
encara el juicio acusado por asesinato
en segundo grado y homicidio
involuntario y a un movimiento que
espera una condena ejemplarizante que
siente precedente
en mi alma al menos dos personas
fallecieron en la última jornada de
protestas contra el golpe militar los
hechos de violencia fueron registrados
en una ciudad en el norte del país en
enfrentamientos con la policía local
según los testigos los fallecidos
recibieron disparos en la cabeza y otras
tres personas también resultaron heridas
las fuerzas de seguridad han respondido
reprimiendo estas protestas en las que
ya se contabilizan 50 fallecidos y 1800
personas han sido detenidas para este
lunes varios sindicatos convocaron a una
huelga general
ofreciendo protección contra posibles
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad hombres armados de la etnia
karen escoltan a unos 2.000
manifestantes en su mayoría profesores y
estudiantes están escuchando los
llamados de los sindicatos a una huelga
general con el objetivo de bloquear la
economía de mianmar
pero no sé
sin embargo la junta advirtió a los
funcionarios que serían despedidos y
continuaban con el boicot el ejército ha
intensificado su represión contra los
manifestantes en los últimos días más de
50 personas han muerto desde el inicio
de las manifestaciones lo que ha
provocado una condena internacional el
lunes australia confirmó que había
suspendido su cooperación de defensa con
mianmar
esas necesidades de desarrollo
humanitario apoyo y enfoque son las que
hemos trabajado con mucho cuidado para
asegurarnos de que todavía podemos
cumplir pero no lo haremos a través de
una agencia gubernamental también hemos
tenido un embargo sobre cualquier venta
militar a mianmar y mantendremos nuestra
política de sanciones bajo estrecha
revisión de eeuu gran bretaña y canadá
han endurecido varias restricciones al
ejército de mianmar pero si bien pueden
ser simbólicamente importantes no está
claro si las sanciones impuestas hasta
ahora tendrán un gran impacto la mayoría
de los principales generales ya están
sancionados y algunos expertos afirman
que la diplomacia sostenida sería más
efectiva
el ejército niega su responsabilidad por
las muertes durante las protestas y ha
defendido la toma de poder alegando
fraude en las elecciones de noviembre
por séptimo día consecutivo los
libaneses se tomaron las calles y
también algunas de las principales
carreteras del país para mostrar su
descontento por la profunda crisis
económica que vive esa nación la moneda
local la libra libanesa ha caído a
niveles históricos agudizando esta
crisis social y política el informe es
de matías a raíz
una nueva muestra de ira por más de un
año de crisis económica y seis meses de
parálisis política por séptimo día
consecutivo los manifestantes quemaron
neumáticos para bloquear las principales
carreteras de líbano hemos dicho varias
veces y repetimos que habrá una escalada
porque no creo que el estado esté
haciendo nada y la gente no solo tiene
hambre sino tiene muchas demandas la
crisis económica que estalló en 2019
llevó a miles de personas a las calles
exigiendo la renuncia del gobierno la
pandemia y la explosión del puerto de
beirut en 2020 sólo agravaron la
situación la pasada semana el valor de
la libra libanesa cayó en un nuevo
mínimo histórico lo que llevó nuevamente
a la ciudadanía a las calles decenas de
miles de empleos se han perdido cuentas
han sido congeladas y el hambre se hace
cada vez más común en la escena del 17
de octubre de 2019 tiene que repetirse y
nos quedaremos en las calles a partir de
hoy serán abiertas ojalá todos se unen a
nosotros para mostrar al mundo entero
que todos estamos unidos que todos
tenemos reivindicaciones que todos
sufrimos y que queremos un cambio el
nuevo primer ministro designado saad
al-hariri acusa al presidente michel aún
de bloquear los avances para formar un
nuevo gobierno en medio de una parálisis
política a líbano no logra llevar a cabo
reformas exigidas por la comunidad
internacional para desbloquear miles de
millones de dólares de ayuda
guinea ecuatorial' el único país hispano
parlante en áfrica se recupera de la
serie de explosiones ocurridas en una
unidad de depósitos explosivos
pertenecientes a las fuerzas armadas de
esa nación de acuerdo con el comunicado
emitido por la presidencia
ecuatoguineana en la ciudad de malabo
las cinco detonaciones dejaron hasta el
momento 15 muertos y más de 500 heridos
así como incalculables daños materiales
en prácticamente todos los edificios y
viviendas de la ciudad debata el motor
económico de ese país el presidente
teodoro obiang afirmó que el accidente
fue ocasionado por negligencia
en otros temas los duques de sants ex el
príncipe harry y su esposa megan marco
le dieron una esperada entrevista a la
reconocida presentadora estadounidense
oprah winfrey en donde hicieron
llamativas revelaciones en sus
comentarios los duques se dieron
detalles íntimos de la vida dentro de la
familia real británica así como la
presión ejercida por el palacio el
racismo la difícil dinámica familiar y
sus pensamientos suicidas también
hablaron de la distante relación con
carlos el príncipe de gales en londres
en la capital británica hasta luisa
pulido corresponsal de france 24 y nos
dan más detalles del impacto que ha
tenido esta entrevista en el reino unido
hasta el momento no se conoce una
declaración del palacio de bukingham u
otro integrante de la familia real sobre
esta escandalosa entrevista del príncipe
harry y su esposa megan marcan pero es
tan delicado lo que afirman que
seguramente y se espera que lo hagan a
lo largo de este día en esta entrevista
que no ha sido vista en la televisión
abierta del reino unido pero se hará
esta noche miguel marco asegura que
cuando estaba embarazada de su hijo
archi había preocupación dentro de la
monarquía sobre el color de piel de su
hijo dado que ella es la primera royal
de herencia afroamericana
megan también asegura que estaba tan
presionada y tan solitaria por el nuevo
cambio de vida en el que no podía ni
salir a la calle sola que pensó en
suicidarse cuando trató de buscar ayuda
profesional y preguntó así a la familia
real no se le permitió buscar esta ayuda
por su parte el príncipe dejarlo y
aseguró que su papá el príncipe carlos
el heredero al trono no le responde sus
llamadas
en varias oportunidades lo cierto es que
esta entrevista dará para un escándalo a
lo largo de esta semana y seguramente de
varias semanas porque afecta la imagen
de la familia real como una institución
más moderna
masnoticias miles de haitianos se
manifestaron este domingo en las calles
de puerto príncipe la capital de ese
país caribeño esta vez contra el
vertiginoso aumento de los secuestros y
de la inseguridad en haití los
ciudadanos rechazan también la violencia
que ha instaurado el presidente joven el
mois a quien critican por no haber
puesto fin a la inseguridad y por haber
presuntamente extendido su mandato
presidencial el informe es de natalia
plazas
en una nueva jornada de protestas contra
el joven el mois miles de ciudadanos
tomaron las calles de puerto príncipe
esta vez para rechazar la constante
violencia y los secuestros en el país
respondieron a una convocatoria del
personal sanitario tras el asesinato de
un médico y de una enfermera
esta es un movimiento del pueblo de
haití de todos los ciudadanos que
creemos que es imposible vivir en este
país no podemos vivir en esta situación
con barricadas ardiendo los
manifestantes pidieron el fin del
mandato de maurice a quien culpan de ser
incapaz de garantizar la seguridad de la
nación
haití ha visto recientemente constantes
secuestros principalmente de personas de
clase media a finales de febrero el
pediatra en espada fue asesinado al
resistirse a un intento de secuestro
pocos días después la enfermera del
inventor murió a manos de dos hombres
cuando salía de un banco cuando hay un
secuestro quiénes son las víctimas somos
nosotros los de la clase media los
médicos los abogados la policía
y la agitación política se ha tornado
permanente en el país caribeño en medio
de una disputa entre la administración
de maurice y la oposición que asegura
que su mandato terminó el 7 de febrero
moix por su parte asegura que le queda
un año más en el cargo
y para conmemorar el día internacional
de la mujer a lo largo de los últimos
días les hemos presentado una serie de
reportajes especiales dedicados a
mujeres que han jugado un papel
fundamental en la pandemia del cob y 19
en nuestro último reportaje vamos a ir a
la ciudad de sao paulo en brasil en
donde encontramos a denis abranches una
cirujana dentista su labor ayudo a miles
de personas a quienes cuido su higiene
oral mientras estaban entubados siendo
atendidos en unidades de cuidados
intensivos esta es la historia
yo soy de anís vine para cuidar de tu
boquita y cuidarte fue hace más de dos
décadas que denis vela por la salud
bucodental de los enfermos en terapia
intensiva
es una paciente de 31 años con un
histórico de leucemia asociado a un
posible cobit está intubada y recibe
ventilación mecánica
ella siente mucho dolor no es agradable
sangre bastante es una segunda puerta
para otras infecciones
con mucha delicadeza denis hidrata la
boca con un gel humectante después
desinfecta las encías y aspira las
secreciones cuida personalmente de cada
paciente
durante el procedimiento un chorro de
saliva salpica el cuello de venice que
abandona rápidamente la sala para
desinfectarse es un accidente recurrente
que no hace mella en su dedicación las
marcas de su esfuerzo están esculpidas
en su rostro
tenemos que intentar que sea un poco más
leve conversar con el paciente pero
sobre todo cuidar del paciente con amor
con cariño porque muchos de ellos sólo
nos centran a nosotros en su momento
final
nosotros sabemos la batalla que ellos se
enfrentan cuando están aquí es doloroso
para nosotros es una muerte muy
solitaria
desde hace semanas brasil registra datos
récord de mortalidad los hospitales de
sant pau no están al borde del colapso
denis que no descansa ni siquiera el día
de su cumpleaños lamenta la falta de
distanciamiento social en el peor
momento de la pandemia
en este momento tenemos que entender que
somos víctimas de un virus que se está
llevando a nuestra familia y eso no es
suficiente para que las personas se
concienticen y usen la mascarilla
cirujana y profesora denise fue la
primera persona en brasil que recibió la
vacuna de astrazéneca participó como
voluntaria en los ensayos para ayudar en
la lucha contra el coronavirus gran
labor con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias en france 24 más información en
france 24 punto com en las redes
sociales y en la app siga con nosotros
buenos días
[Música]
francés